hi everyone it's jerry
let's have a look at a game from the
2010
world blitz chess championship this is a
game i only recently stumbled upon
between demetri and draken on the white
end
and sergey karyakin it's a brief game
only a 10 mover
and one you may have guessed involves
an opening trick or trap it was
very surprising and instructive really
for me to see a player of karjakin's
caliber go down
so quickly he has been for the longest
time
a 2700 plus player initially reaching
that
level at the age of 17 and he's only
built on it from there
i recognize this is a blitz game a
faster time control and mistakes are
bound to happen
but still instructive and surprising
defeat
so let's hop right to it opening wise we
have an english
in english three nights variation
after g6 pay particular attention to the
big gaps
f6 and h6 earlier on
it's the f6 square but both of these
will play a big role these two gaps in
black's house will play a role
in this quick defeat so
how to try to take advantage of that f6
square first of all
we need to get our dark square bishop
contributing
so it's first d4 after e takes d4
this is where we have an atypical reply
not the recapture but rather knight d5
immediately keying in on
f6 bishop g7
bishop g5 it's now both white queenside
miners
coordinating on this square
how to defend the queen's under fire pop
quiz
what move would you play here is black
feel free to pause the video
okay the move played in the game is
knight
g to e7 this is a losing move
but maybe not crystal clear as to why
that's the losing move you may be
tempted to go with some move right here
i know i was
in reply to knight g to e7
may not be clear how you punish this
last move
before i go down this line
and show why this is a losing move
let me point out what the best move is
the best move
is knight c to e7 i'd like to just add a
couple reasons
uh to support
this this move right here to share why
this is considered best for one
black does not give up control over f6
right away
king knight is still there and two
the white knight on d5 is soon to be
given a boot
with c6 in fact the bishop on g5 is also
ready to be given a boot
the two white miners that are in black's
house
will be kicked away alright
after knight g to e7
how to take advantage of this the
tempting move for me
in this position was to put the knight
right into f6
and i imagine with all this talk so far
i've
i've shared about that f6 square many of
you went in this direction
ah the knight gets to jump in with check
black's gonna have to go uncastled
you don't want to give up the bishop for
night either and say
uh you know if if you actually go for
this white is better the rook moves
how are you ever getting rid of this guy
yeah that's not a good option what is
best here is to play king to fa in this
position black is actually better
black is the one who's generating a
threat now black's uncastled but
is ready to go with h6 bishop backing up
g5
and then win the knight let's also not
forget
black is still up upon in this position
white has yet to recapture it
what is the way to win in this position
as white
another pop quiz white to move how do
you punish black's last move
okay the winning continuation the move
played in the game is
knight takes on d4 only now
okay what's happening here let's see
for starters if knight takes knight
this is one of those painful moves
you get the piece back and you're
getting the queen
soon enough that hurts
uh let's also note what the threat here
is
let's just say black makes a dummy move
a passing move
a6 the idea here is to get rid of
the defender of e7 and then take the
knight
i guess that would be best but still the
issue here is that white is winning a
minor piece
so what do we do
bishop takes knight that's the move that
was played
the follow-up here one more pop quiz
feel free to pause the video
here we go queen takes bishop
that's cool i really like this
continuation
you're giving up the queen why well if
knight takes queen
they would follow a checkmate in two and
how cool is that
those two gaps on f6
and h6 that's checkmate
knight on f6 bishop on h6
do the job so
what does karjakin play these dark
squares are officially
broken down there is no save here
black castles walks right into
knight f6 check if the king goes to h7
we have our pick which double check do
we want
that one looks cool followed up with
made on g7
and well okay if king g7 that's what we
could do in the game king h8 is played
and now we have the final move of the
game knight to g4
karjakin resigns there are only three
moves
in this position excuse me four moves so
let's let's point them out you could
move the king to g8
you could block the check like this
block the check like that or capture the
queen
let's go through each one by one king g8
knight h6 this should this is a move
that's going to surface in
pretty much every variation from here on
out that's mate
another variation f6 we would take on
f6 king here that's me
rook takes bishop we take with the queen
favorite square for the knight again h6
and are we there yet night block okay
that's nothing gonna be we know what's
happening there
in the final variation
knight takes queen remember earlier
there was a knight on f6
and then bishop on h6
they switch roles in this variation
this time bishop f6 knight h6
once more mate this is a
beautiful way to capitalize on these two
gaps
f6 and h6 it's really really cool for me
to see this
early queen sacrifice leading to
a complete collapse of the dark squares
on the king's side
anyhow i hope you found this one
instructive as well
feel free as usual to leave any comments
in the comments section below
and i'll catch you in the next video
that's all for now take care
bye
you